[Musique]
dans les débats autour de l' affaire
polanski et de sa remise de césar du
meilleur réalisateur vendredi dernier
deux clans sont bien distincts ce qui
favorise la parole des victimes et qui
pensent que roman polanski devrait être
en prison et qu'il n'a donc plus le
droit de faire des films et ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut dissocier l'homme de
l'artiste et parfois des victimes de
violences sexuelles peuvent aussi
défendre cette seconde théorie c'est par
exemple le cas d'isabelle morini bosc
qui nous racontait cette semaine dans
l'émission avoir été victime
d'agressions sexuelles à plusieurs
reprises pourtant elle s'est exprimée en
faveur du réalisateur pour elle le
réalisateur doit pouvoir être
récompensée pour son travail
moi c'est pas ma notion de jeu
démocratique du tout j'ai été élevé dans
le respect de les autres et ça vraiment
ça le cimer alors selon vous isabelle at
elle raison de soutenir roman polanski
alors merci à juliette martiaux d'être
avec merci beaucoup juliette versé
militante pour le droit des femmes vous
êtes fondateur de body double pour aider
les femmes à se sentir mieux et bravo
donc déjà pour pour ce que vous faites
merci juliette vous avez poussé un coup
de gueule sur la sphère pour lens qui
dans une vidéo publiée sur twitter on va
voir on va revoir votre vidéo et c'est
vrai que vous ça vous fait mal au coeur
les gens qui soutiennent romane pour
lens qui ça vous dérange énormément
enfin qui dit voilà on va regarder vous
allez nous dire pourquoi vous dites
qu'ils devraient me devriez même pas à y
avoir de polémique concernant oman
polanski pour vous déjà ça c'est
complètement fou regard marche je
voudrais agir sur la polémique
polanski est anti pédophilie ou pro
pédophilie aux le choix du lot
d'ailleurs ça martèle ce job de
danseuses oui je me suis à moitié fait
agresser sexuellement et quand j'en ai
parlé au chorégraphe mais aussi des
machines ont l'air d'hésiter défendent
les droits des êtres humains qui me font
confiance ou en commission que je prends
sur eux au passage à pas facile là
encore choisi dieu moi j'ai envie
d'avoir votre avis sur plein de choses
se séparent juliette vraiment je suis à
prendre demain
bon ben c'est bien parce que vous dites
donc c'est vrai que voilà il a du talent
sa porte et sa porte les gens à
confusion
vous dites on se pose les mauvaises
questions d'enfants alors pour moi c'est
ça la polémique elle est simple ces pros
pédophilie ou anti pédophilie maintenant
effectivement la source de cette
polémique elle est bien plus profonde
que ça ce qui pousse les gens dans la
confusion
c'est que le gars est censé avoir du
talent je descends c'est parce que moi
j'ai jamais vu aucun de ceux fils
d'accord donc on se dit si le gars a du
talent c'est qui peut pas être si
mauvais que ça mais non ça veut dire que
c'est pas un banquier
il laisse pas son costume au placard
quand ils rentrent le soir n'ont
retourné à un artiste on est passionné
et quand on est passionné on les 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
donc on peut pas dissocier à mon sens
l'homme de l'artiste cette fois qu'une
seule personne
vous prenez parce que il a belle voilà
c'est vrai que cette vidéo tourne
partout
c'est vrai que ce que vous avez à
répondre à juliette monte à 10 a alors
tout ce que j'ai compris par contre je
trouve que c'est une simplification de
tellement de choses d'abord juger
quelqu'un et dire je n'ai vu aucun de
ses films ça me choque
mara ainsi par manque en jeu juste que
je suis moi je te fasse ça me dégoûte en
fait à prix bas mais c'est la vision
d'un pédophile sur des longs métrages et
autant plus que je suis comédienne que
je suis actrice je peux pas regarder ça
parce que pendant bien des eaux
c'est cautionner ça bien ça alors je
voulais juste isabelle pour vraiment
pourrais-je pas pour défendre juliette
mais moi j'étais avec un pote se dit tu
vois là qu il a rien à voir il pas du
tout dans le milieu du cinéma tout ça il
m'a dit moi voilà je ne vais je n'irai
jamais voir un film de roman polanski
après il m'a dit chacun fait ce qu'il
veut mais voilà c'était son avis ou
alors oui chacun festival a effectué un
message au ministre était il était
nourri un légume julia talent qu'est ce
que vous lui répondez moi je comprends
je cautionne pas mais je comprends votre
carnet fusil j'ai un cerveau à jeun
l'esprit ch capable de comprendre
d'entendre ce que vous mais j'ai encore
rien je suis et je suis désolé on va
grandir dans le sens où pour vous
jacchus vous avez rien aussi j'en
attends les images ici sont déjà cuites
est un bon film pour vous si on vous
avait pas dit jacques hull c'est un film
de polanski c'est un film sur
l'antisémitisme le film halo reach vous
seriez allé le voir
non c'est non si on ne parle que de ça
je le sais mais ce n'est pas dans ce
film de cet ehpad romane voitures voilà
néanmoins j'accuse
roman polanski qui réalise en film
s'appelle jacques hull est ce que vous
savez que c'est
non 01 20 ans qui réalise que celle
inception du fait n'est pas une phrase
de polanski le j'accuse
bien sûr que si je veux dire tu as bien
tu as dû répondre à la question
pour faire face à la crise s'il vous
plaît alors si c'était pas drômois le
bras est recherché par interpol dans les
circuits les juliette ci s'était pas
réalisé par roman polanski est ce que
vous auriez telle voie ça dépend réalisé
à quelqu'un et ça organisé par n'importe
qui je sais pas je peux pas dire et si
avec des si on refait le monde cette
année
oui la lampe apparent les hater
pédophiles est accusée d'avoir excusez
moi d'accord viol et de chercher des
gamines de dinan il n'a pas été utilisé
de premier temps il a reconnu les faits
comme quoi il avait 13 ans a été
condamné à 90 jours mais pas des biens
des macarons ou deux ans qu'il est moins
bon endroit n'ont pas besoin de moi je
voulais pas parler d'histoire mais
puisque vous en parlez vous même
nettement résumé très très brièvement
match nul respectivement 42 jours en
prison
et quand il apprit qu'il vente
éventuellement pouvait nouvellement
remettre 50 ans il est là effectivement
partie il est venu à paris puisqu'il est
né à paris et alors le juge a fini par
être démis de cette affaire il ya des
failles énormes aux états unis on a fini
par reconnaître qu'il avait fait son
temps de prison complet puisque en 2009
il a été arrêté en suisse qu'il a fait
deux mois qu'il a été assigné les eaux
de rejet j'y arrive pas metz demain
maman gérer ces matches de ma maman sur
les neuf à son capot de ma mère
jsms de ma maman qui me dit c'est mon
cas pour j'accuse
je ne savais pas que c'était polanski je
suis allé le voir et j'ai adoré et en
sortant papa m'a dit c'est polanski j'ai
dit ah merde voilà donc je vous dis est
là elle ne sait pas qui c'est on va dire
lorsqu'elle a fait celui qui a une plus
de prix y compris en 2014 pour un film
quand ils s'affichent dans le monde
aujourd'hui de tout ce dont j'avais
acquise et ya passé plus d'avoir drogué
la personne farrell article du monde aux
gens non attentes mais je suis allé vous
allez répondre dans un instant passé au
deuxième
au deuxième de la deuxième question vous
allez pouvoir le dire faut-il retirer le
césar de roman polanski le césar du
meilleur réalisateur décerné à roman
polanski a choqué énormément de monde et
pas que des people puisque des
internautes se sont mobilisés pour
demander l'annulation de cette
récompense
on vous a résumé tout ça juste avant
vous avez vous comprenez que florence
foresti et quitter la salle bien sûr
mais pourquoi la paroisse n'est pas venu
du froid n'est pas venue du tout elle
n'est pas parvenue à lui tout est ce que
peut-être que l a vu l'opportunité de
faire passer un message est de dire
qu'il n'était pas d'accord je sais pas
je connais pas florence personnellement
fallu nommer elle non mais juste quand
on fait un travail ont pu jusqu au bout
mais je ne sais pas moi je connais pas
florence il faudra personnes nommées est
ce que vous vous si vous devez être
comédienne si vous deviez présenter la
cérémonie
vous vous seriez duction richesse que
vous récemment présenté la cérémonie moi
là je n'ai jamais reconnu dit non à
céret met d'ailleurs gpo font toujours
les deux les oscars et les césar je me
suis jamais rencontré à la sauce car il
ya des moyens existants et cesaria
personnes je vous trouve ravissante vous
confondez big autre chose le fait que je
sois ravissante si j'avais été moche
c'est quoi mais non vous plaît juliette
et raymond savoie tous soient les doulas
la question sur le fait qu'elle
présentera les vachement bien parce que
moi je comprends son point de vue et à
la raison et à des convictions et tu dis
tu te bats pour les femmes et tous et et
c'est vachement bien et j'ai entendu que
tu dis tu peux être comédienne août et
comédienne je suis comédien moi je suis
danseuse du fait que ça c'est bien
j'ai une question à te poser si demain
ce que moi je suis le plus con de la
bande si demain après mois sur france 3
france 2 canal+ et la gaumont te propose
un rôle au cinéma
j'accepte ou pas mais dans quelles
conditions d'un contrat un bon rôle a
dit que cette maison est ce que tu as en
cdi est-ce que tu accepterais un rôle de
gaumont canal+ france 2 france 3 tous
ces gens vont financer le fai vive
l'anarchie
réalisé par ma mère ou stephen âmes a
réalisé par l'elysée ok tu acceptes oui
elle est pourtant la gaumont à financer
j'accuse parce que ça sinon ciel était
plus dans tes principes ben on pourrait
chapeauter plus dans les droits de la
femme c'est des mecs combien d'écoles à
des gens c'est des gens qu'on me
polanski debout bah oui ils ont fait ils
ont créé pour ils ont créé j'accuse
gourou les pressions ou non ils font ce
qu'ils valent beaucoup moins physique de
l'agent pour lens qui est alors ben may
politiciens mais des aménagements et lui
donner raison en est ce qu'on m'a appelé
pour me proposer
est ce que vous seriez jouer juliette
juliette laisser ce que vous auriez
jouer dans j'accuse maintenant
jamais de la vie bien sûr que non ce que
vous auriez présenter la cérémonie des
césar sachant que roman polanski était
nommé douze fois je me suis je voulais
dijon faisait déjà longtemps je me suis
jamais trembler non mais oui on en rit
beaucoup mon nom alors attendez qu'on va
voir présent l'on récapitule le
récapitulatif de la mobilisation et a
beaucoup qui veulent retirer le césar de
roman polanski
j'ai envie de savoir l'avis des
téléspectateurs la nature faut-il lui
retirer son césar sais pas
alors que le film j'accuse du
réalisateur roman polanski a été nommé à
deux reprises lors de la 45e cérémonie
des césar l'homme au coeur de la
tourmente pour les multiples accusations
de viol sur mineure à son encontre a
reçu le césar du meilleur réalisateur
une distinction qui divise de nombreuses
personnalités si certaines soutiennent
l'idée qu'il est acceptable d'honorer le
travail de roman polanski comme gilles
lellouche
isabelle morini bosc mimie mathy ou
encore fanny ardant d'autres soutiennent
au contraire l'attitude de la crise
adèle haenel qui a décidé de quitter la
salle pour s'opposer à cet honneur fait
aux réalisateurs parmi elles on retrouve
alexandra lamy a dès l'exercice polo
sara forestier ou encore jessica
chastain aujourd'hui ce sont des
internautes qui ont eux aussi décidé de
protester contre ce césar une pétition
demandent le retrait de ce prix
honorifique totalement déplacé selon les
signataires sur le site de la pétition
on peut lire le texte suivant alors non
non ne sépare pas l'homme de l'artiste
c'est le même homme qui violent et qui
fait les films c'est le même homme qui
violent et qui remporte les prix c'est
le même homme qui violent et qui empoche
l'argent alors peu importe le talent et
le génie on ne sépare pas l'homme de
l'artiste à l'heure actuelle plus de
28000 personnes ont signé cette pétition
alors selon vous faut-il retirer son
césar arman polanski alors isabelle
pauthier laure manaudou question
caricaturale champagne façon
caricaturale pour moi non je souhaite
qu'il se soumet un film je soutiens un
film polanski est un homme qui a des
failles est un homme qui est l'une des
souffrances parce que voir sa femme
assassinée de 16 coups de couteau dans
le ventre ça n'est pas rien surtout pour
un mec qui l'a confondu avec un autre
locataire
l'histoire ne dit rien mais je
m'explique je n'exclus rien mais je me
rappelle que le soir des saisons on m'a
dit cet homme mérite de souffrir un jour
maintenant il a déjà souffert lui aussi
ce grand mélange absolument tout dedans
en espérant que ça va passer le droit
des femmes si complexe au plus pressé
c'est confirmé c'est la synergie des
enseignements plus complexe mais si on
m'avait dit un jour que je serais mise
en accusation pour soutenir un film
qu'on vous dirait votre passé avoué le
film je dirais mais on mélange tout mais
je pense que de plus en plus la fin
mélange aux eaux ainsi qu'à une espèce
d'hystérie collective là-dessus qu'en
2014 il a une dont le prix a pas cesare
dans tous les festivals pour la vénus à
la fourrure elle était où les féministes
elles étaient ou affirme contestable de
tes questions de sexualité
personne ne s'est mis debout comme on
danse c'est ce film mais ça criait
j'ai n'ai pas qu'elles sont exigées il
faut lui retirer son césar c'est une
faute et une provocation
ceux-ci pas l'homme de l'artiste il a
commis des fautes tout a changé une
nouvelle révélation depuis 2014
donc il faut absolument lui retirer ça
parce que sinon ça va rester il y aura
plus de césar si on lui retire pas cette
mobilisation elle montre que des
victimes des femmes des hommes sont
choqués oui absolument lui retirer à jcs
qu'il faut lui retirer sur césar
j'aurais qu'on voit un extrait si le
jean pierre darroussin donc a refusé de
prononcer le nom de polanski hors de
remettre le césar de la meilleure
adaptation
et c'est vrai que derrière et ils sont
des projets plein la gueule
jean pierre darroussin à regarder et le
césar de la meilleure adaptation est
attribué à mme amos qui est robert
harris pourra que les concernés n'étant
pas là l'académie fera en sorte de
pouvoir les contacter et leur remettre
cette statuette qui est une très belle
statue est malgré tout vraiment vraiment
mais c'est moi je trouve ça ridicule je
trouve ça ridicule de sa part n'ayez pas
peur dit son nom il ya qu une femme qui
a prononcé son nom à la fin permanent
pour quand elle l'a dit mais lui il est
ridicule mais cc c'est des foutaises
keane en train de raconter de bégayer
comme ça je laime bien comme acteur mais
là pour moi il a fait la moyenne même
déçu parce qu'il l'encensé ya quelques
années c'est vrai qu'il en soit les
quelques années encore jean pierre
darroussin c'est ce qu'on dit tous les
acteurs oui valeurs et à celles qui
polluent retirer le césar ou pas à moi
je trouve qu'ils fouillent fait qu'ils
vont maintenant il faut le retirer
effectivement il effectivement parce que
c'est un vrai problème ça fera devient
salée signer la pétition qui est capable
de signer la pétition sommet pour le bac
est capable de signer la pétition lui
retirer le cesa parce que c'est bien
beau de dire ça ici voilà c'est
hypocrite on met un mec debout moi je
les dis ici qu avant la sortie du film
j'ai dit que j'irai voir film je me pète
et loire l'ironie du sort c'est que j'ai
même porté lors j'ai pu le temps on met
un mec de bourreau mec qui devrait en
taule
on devrait l'extrader la france
n'extrade pas il devrait en prison il
n'est pas en prison il est libre elle a
dit j'ai un examen qui fait des films
donc dehors depuis 2014
il fait son film j'accuse ça paye dedans
des coiffeurs des maquilleuses toute une
équipe de tournage des tas de personnes
ont reçu de l'argent de ce film là
l'état donné de l'argent tout le monde
avait de l'argent valérie pécresse a
même dit je regrette que le conseil qui
est président du conseil d'île de france
je regrette que le conseil dit de france
aient financé ce film là on le met au
bout on le nomme 12 fois dans 12
catégories et ensuite un peu d'info l
égard des gardes on le fout en tôle et
pan c'est cool mais alors quel visage
est ridé c'est là on le donne accès à
prendre thierry frémont conan faut
dénoncer le finir non non non tu
corriges une faute quand arrivait à 6h
vue d'arriver à 6h asa 5h45 tuco resta
faute là c'est une saint viaud l'heure
on corrige pas une faute où il est libre
et il fait des films et on laisse se
mettre debout et l'état finance les
films et les chaînes finance les films
et à ce moment là après faut pas venir
pleurer derrière où on le fout en taule
c'est pas plus compliqué que ça il a
coûté un cachot il est honteux
alors si l'on y ajoute l on y verte et
qu'est ce que vous êtes en train de vous
embrouiller pour rien même toit
[Applaudissements]
tous les gens c'est pour ça je sais pas
trop d'accord et isabelle s'est classé
pas le pape a parlé du film jacques
zimmer de la cause c'est pas le meilleur
film qui a été élu et c'est le meilleur
réalisateur
donc c'est ce que je lis mon fils et
connaissent aussi l'homme de l'artiste
sauf que celle qui a été récompensé donc
la saq pose quand même un problème plus
grave et tu nous a bouleversés et avec
ton témoignage sur l'agression sexuelle
tu as vécu il ya quatre ans on était
tous bien vous bouleverser pour toi et
tu as eu la dignité de le raconter avec
tes mots et c'était très émouvant mais
là je te pose la question si c'était
polanski qui il ya quatre ans avait
violé est-ce que tu aurais été
l'applaudir ou césar maman du soir
puisque la vie sociale je vais te
réfères de faire une réponse aussi
basique très bonne question
polanski ce n'est pas absolument pas
polanski qui m'a violets n'ont cessé
d'applaudir
oui tu me dire que c'est à l'artiste
c'est pas l'homme que je viens de dire
ça mais on va arrêter de mettre en
accusation et non je vous propose une
section isolée polanski m'avait gueuler
je l'aurais dit avant bien avant ce que
tu aurais tu es là pour dire qu'en
disent 'ok de film est bon mais si
ç'avait été le film j'accuse je pense à
l'avenir je serais allé voir le film de
tout savoir le film de votre violeur non
mais on joue comme ça je sonnais parce
qu'on aurait sacré un gars comme ça que
vous seriez senti sale alors si je
chante ses femmes comme ces femmes qui
ont été victimes de viols par lui ou pas
et qui on vous dit et qui est qui ont vu
cette scène se passait sous les yeux
d'un mec qui est sacré alors oui faut
lui retirer le césar parce que c'est
symbolique un moment donné il faut taper
sur le genre l'âge de 6 mois mais c'est
la vie destinée à s'en sortir tranquille
alors on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs bien qu'est ce que dit
qu'est ce que dit oui à 56% celles qui
pensent qu'il faut qu'il garde son césar
autour de la table du rabbinat l'orateur
a dit mathieu vraiment où il y aura un
arrangement non match est perdu ou moi
je trouve qu'on me sens surtout moi
aussi que c'est un sirh je trouve que
c'est un gars je trouve que en voulant
défendre la cause des femmes vous en
faites une caricature mais parce qu'en
fait le problème c'est que vous dites
il va en prison en fait c'est pas sûr
qu'il aille en prison parce qu'il a déjà
été jugé qu'on sait pas il faut qu'à
nous
était jugé le vrai j'ai le vrai problème
et moi j'ai eu une conversation avec ma
fille hier soir quand je suis rentré par
rapport aux témoignages de lisa c'est
pour moi le vrai problème de tout ce
problème là c'est la prescription
c'est à dire que comme aujourd'hui il ya
une prescription au bout d'une certaine
période
c'est cette voie qu'il faudra déjà ces
sommes ne peuvent savourer et on ne peut
plus juger ça c'est moi que l'on change
d'option les premiers sont déjà on y met
déjà elles sont où je jouais de la vie
et donc là on aime et vous savez
pourquoi c'est pas vie parce qu'on ya
catherine viel on a changé c'est celle
et c'est justement que par rapport à la
shoah ou là il ya une prescription avis
et je pense qu'il faut que ça change a
aussi fait sa chose
et pour l'instant je trouve qu'on libère
pas la porte mais de grâce ne monte pas
les femmes et hommes et les autres mais
jamais non mais si jamais je n aurais
pas fait d'être une victime l'air comme
ça mais bien sûr que je lui ai dit voilà
moi chacun fait comme je vous ai dit je
comprends ce que vous dites parce que
j'ai un cerveau un esprit je ne
cautionne pas je ne suis pas d'accord
c'est ce qu'on appelle la divergence
d'opinion c'est pour ça qu'on est tous
là c'est un débat non sur ça on peut
faire avancer les uns les autres et même
maintenant moi je suis une féministe et
je pars du principe que toutes les
femmes ont une valeur et que le vrai
pouvoir on réussira à la voir le jour où
justement on arrivera à gérer toutes les
unes les autres vers le haut et a pas
descendre il n'y a pas d'échelle c'est
pas une compétition n'y a pas une
échelle de dilution des parts soit dorée
de victimes des victimes ou pas dit
d'accord il faut pas entrer dans les
moeurs la victime victime moi que moi je
fais très vite mes potes logique moi
j'ai crié au scandale lorsque les le
film est une deux nominations à partir
non le film est nommé il peut être
allergique il est nommé il faut que tous
les comités tous ceux qui votent bas du
cou vote comme si c'était un film lambda
et qu'on oublie la personne parce que si
l'élu 0 prix ça voudrait dire on l'a
nommé mais finalement on juste plus le
film donc une fois qu'il est nommé non
juge
on y va comme si c'était rien et ici
mérite son prix et qu'il a alors il faut
du gard des césar ça fera jurisprudence
ça fera bouger les jambes derrière mais
qui garde son césar parce que le côté je
te nomme je te le fige tant rêver tout
s'est passé par les camps n'ont pas
également aux données sur la nommer les
vagues et des sons cesag longueur de la
même manière mademoiselle la présence de
la daily mail qui est une actrice
absolument extraordinaire et non dans un
film extraordinaire justement rentrée on
va voir le départ d'adele est d'accord
regarder on va revoir puisque et
regardez on va passer au troisième volet
c'est les stars qui parle me tell leur
carrière en danger et on va enchaîner
avec la cia
madame la présidente d'honneur madame
sandrine kiberlain
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vrai que ça et là comme un
courage de croyable oui elle est
absolument extraordinaire et en plus
elle aurait mérité moi à mon sens par
rapport au film café mais peu importe qu
en tête quand il ya douze nominations
auxquelles elle s'assoit dans ce théâtre
elle sait qui est actuellement à ce
qu'il soit éventuellement oui mais c'est
un nouvel complexe que ça vous savez moi
quand j'ai commencé à être actrice à des
gens qui m'ont clairement dit va falloir
que tu restes un terrain neutre un
terrain vierge pour que le réalisateur
puisse projeter leurs fantasmes sur toi
si tu vas tu actrice il ne faut pas
t'exprimer il ne faut pas prendre parti
il ne faut pas exprimer des idées aux
que tous les autres principes c'est
tellement c'est tellement complexe nat
une femme ça c'était d'aujourd'hui et en
plus est une femme on n'est pas des huit
mois j'ai dû gérer eux mêmes la force de
calaire d'avoir mis jettait beaucoup
beaucoup trop talentueuse pour qu'un
simple le job puisse arrêter ma carrière
et c'est ce que je fais pour les droits
des femmes tous les jours en même temps
en les poussant à prendre la parole ont
leur expliquons que non qu'elles sont
beaucoup trop forte
beaucoup trop intelligente beaucoup trop
doué pour qu'un simple film puisse
arrêter locale ou qu'une simple menace
qui s'arrêtait locale et puis c'est
surtout ce truc
ce silence dans lequel on essaye de non
muté depuis des années à nous faire
croire que si on parle tout va s'arrêter
aujourd'hui à plusieurs femmes qui parle
et ça choque tout le monde mais exclut
les hommes c'est tant mieux
qu'est ce qui dans votre discours c'est
terrible je trouve qu'il ya quelque
chose d'inquiétant vraiment un moment
que c'est un monde qui exclut les sommes
qu'il faut qu'ils fassent surface tout
petit c'est parce que ça c'est moi
j'adore les adore j'aime les femmes mais
j'aime les âmes mais j'ai désormais les
lectures vous êtes des gens mais ce
serait serré un monde binaire ce voile
attendant kampala
c'est votre vision qui lèche le volet
non à ça la polémique c'est l'avenir que
toute l'académie de toute l'académie des
césar qui est compromis beaucoup se
demandent si cette cérémonie peut se
relever du scandale polanski en 45 ans
les césars ou eu leur lot de polémiques
mais va-t-elle survivre à cette île
faut-il arrêter les césar on vous pose
la question et nous regarder petit récap
c'est en 1976 que la cérémonie des césar
a été créé en france pour faire
concurrence aux oscars américains dont
la première édition s'était déroulée 50
ans plus tôt une cérémonie qui aura mis
en lumière les grandes oeuvres du
septième art de ces dernières décennies
mais les césar c'est aussi un spectacle
qui a marqué l'histoire de la télé comme
lorsqu'en 1982
jacques martin accompagné de michel
legrand a transformé la salle en école
des fans ou encore en 1992
vanessa paradis se trompe de rom et en
créant un malaise mais aussi un moment
culte de télé césar est attribué à
judith godrèche temps et comment oublier
ce discours poignant d'annie girardot
lorsqu'elle reçoit le césar de la
meilleure actrice en 1996 pour les
misérables
votre témoignage votre amour me font
penser que peut-être je dis bien
peut-être je suis pas encore tout à fait
mort si les moments cultes ont marqué
des générations l'histoire de cette
cérémonie a aussi été jonché de
polémique
la sortie de route de mathilde seigner
en 2012 avec joey starr juste je
voudrais qu'ils montent didier parce que
j'adore je suis ravi que tu l'aies
michel mais je suis une ex fin je vois
la part dont la grève des intermittents
en 2006 ou encore le coup de gueule de
dany boon en 2009
mais c'est en 2017 que le premier grand
scandale est arrivé lorsque l'académie a
souhaité désigner en tant que président
de cette 42e édition le réalisateur
roman polanski à l'époque déjà cette
idée avait fait scandale et sous la
pression l'académie avait dû renoncer à
son choix 2020 est sans conteste l'année
qui décroche la palme de l'édition la
plus mouvementée
si les douze nominations de roman
polanski et son césar de meilleur
réalisateur sont aujourd'hui au coeur de
la polémique c'est aussi cette année que
brad pitt a refusé le césar d'honneur
que souhaitait lui remettre l'académie
c'est en 2020 toujours que le comité de
direction présidé jusqu'à lors par alain
terzian a été poussé dehors suite à une
tribune signée par 400 personnalités
une chose est sûre cette 45e édition
mouvementée a laissé des traces
profondes qui risque de marquer la
cérémonie pour encore longtemps
alors juliette je vous dis un truc qui
sort sur les réseaux sociaux parce que
je savais pas du tout il ya plein de
gens qui disent je vous dis tout le
monde dit que vous venez de ces crêtes
je vous défie cyclable story tout à fait
là disant voilà et que vous dites on dit
ce n'est pas le lieu du féminisme
qu'est ce que c'est à 10 ans mais je
vous dise pour les réseaux actuels
qu'est-ce que ça on mélange tout là on
mélange tout là c'est vraiment une
brocante c'est d'avoir eu deux dents et
on espère que ça va c'est à dire bien
sûr qu'ils ont été reconnus
[Applaudissements]
il n'existait pas ce sont les réseaux
juste jean-michel parce que je veux ce
qu'ils disent qu'ils veulent on doit
arrêter les ces dames ce qu'ils disent
oui oui bonjour oui moubarak faut
arrêter belle façon la sarre et c'est
devenu un tel bordel c'est une mascarade
une à cette façon nous une série
ministre ou qui n'intéressait que les
professionnels de la profession financé
par des chaînes qui finançait donc
rentrer un peu dans leurs
investissements kitchen que l'on
m'attend ça ne représente plus rien que
c'est telle polémique et que les acteurs
mais tsonga d'entre eux qu'on arrête
cette mascarade je vous dis façon on est
preneur à millions 2 qui sont destinés
aux césar fait autre chose avec quoi on
y voit la fête met à l'honneur
je me fais du cinéma devrait
officiellement de toute façon ça plan et
continuer à vivoter mais c'est mort sous
sa forme actuelle faut arrêter tout ça
ces gens étaient hors sol depuis des
années désignons